so first before we start Kathy a big
thank you and thank you to Matt for
creating this opportunity a big thank
you to Chad nakash for helping me you
know think through a few things to say
and I also want to say a big thank you
to everybody here in the auditorium
today for me coming back as an alum you
are the embodiment of the Stanford
community and I feel like I owe such an
incredible debt to this community that I
appreciate you giving me this
opportunity if you look at it I had this
fun conversation with a with a cautious
i was trying to figure out what topics
to hit on he said so tell me a little
bit about you know why stay in school
right well let me give you a couple
reasons two of my board members right
now at big switch are actually
professors at Stanford or lead vc nao to
started teaching classes of Stanford out
of the first 20 people in the company
about a third had been TAS at Stanford
in the cs department while doing their
graduate work and i met my wife as a
grad student when we're both grad
students here at Stanford so I hope
those are at least a few good reasons to
uh to stay in classes here yeah I've
been very lucky over the last 15 years
to I've started one division of a
medium-sized company I've started to
products in the context of a larger
company and most recently started a
company myself they're not as different
as they sound on paper well in fact the
experience has been pretty similar and
over that period I've a recruited I
count at one point somewhere on 300
people to join these different
entrepreneurial adventures now one
really really common theme now if you
find yourself in this position I'm
guessing a fair number of people in this
room will
if you hire well you wind up recruiting
a lot of people that have more
experience than you do and you faced
with challenge of how do you get all
these people with more experience than
you have and very often very different
experience on the same page so there's
this technique that I really like a lot
of giving people books I found it helps
I please copy it and I was hoping to
really talk most today about the books
that I give away we'll talk about these
bees each and a little bit but before we
go in there since most of the stories
that I have to tell today or are about
my company about big switch let me just
do a little bit of background on big
switch so that you get some some context
we started the company in 2010 the ice
was a friend of mine was in it was an
assistant professor of anna cs
department at the time but we had
actually been friends from bases 10
years before we we started this thing
really was really to commercialize his
research and when we started 2010 the
stuff was it was really arcane over the
next two years we became kind of a
darling of the networking industry of an
aging industry it was desperate
desperate for innovation and so we had
all these articles like like this one it
was wonderful high-flying times but the
product wasn't actually done yet Bella
heard the story before the we were just
coming up on our v1 dot o when our most
important technology partner acquired
our only competitor we were suddenly
left in this funny situation we're
critically dependent on a series of
legacy networking vendors that compete
against Cisco for parts of our
technology stack and over the course of
nine months one by one every single
member of this coalition we've put
together designed us out dia we put
together a plan that we put in front of
the board in early 2013 it was a kind of
a sort of a double down plan it said hey
instead of working with all of these
partners for switch software we're going
to go ahead and build the full
technology stack by ourselves and
instead of going to market through them
we're going to go all the way to market
directly it was a bold plan everybody in
the company is really excited about it
via we go into this big board
presentation and we got laughed out of
the room I very specifically remember
one of our board members saying guys
this plan is awful but you have my money
and the board meetings almost over so go
on ahead and do it that's how things
started yeah we scrambled out an
entry-level product in late 13 by 2014
we began to have some revenue coming in
so revenue was starting to trickle in
and frankly you know the growth path
wasn't wasn't too too bad now summer
2014 I forget exactly who was somebody
one of the management team meeting said
he knows this this intro product we've
got we've never lost and that was kind
of surprised everybody involved the
other things the beta for our flagship
product was going well and like really
well I mean people were loving the early
beta code that we had to get it so by
the second half of the year things were
there was a sort of electricity in the
air it's kind of something good is
happening here and we can't quite put
our finger on what it is but but we know
something is happening I want you to
keep your eye on
chart so this is a about the zen
pipeline chart it's the total sales
pipeline that you snapshot every month
and if you're in enterprise tech you
kind of you spend a lot of time living
with this chart and I want you to look
very very closely because here's what
happened next that's what you really
want to see this was a really really
good time for the company this is sort
of the the eye of the tornado that we're
in right now as this started happening
more and more people started seeing and
touching and feeling loving the product
you know we suddenly had this foot raft
of awards want to GART which one Gartner
award we're now finalists for the best
of interoperable outs next month this
has just been a phenomenal ride these
startups any of these whether it's in a
big company or your own company it's not
a linear process that we go through here
ah and it takes a ton of luck but
certainly one thing that I've found is
that the harder I work at these and the
longer I stay in it the luckier I've
gotten and we'll come back to that in a
bit let's for wine a little bit because
I when I was an undergrad no I don't
know how how you sort of picture the
next couple of years rolling out for you
but for me I had this vision of being a
very general business leader it's really
what I wanted to do but I started my
career as a Java developer was the best
job that I could get yeah and when I
think about my early career break out
moments they weren't from being a
general business leader they were
actually from being an expert in some
possibly very arcane corner of
technology
via my first company cyan't there were
five of us that had this kind of
semi-professional hobby of doing mobile
development and you see palm OS here
this was like way before mobile
development was cool via we had enough
customer demand when the company that
the management team decided to formalize
a practice around this and I wound up
leading that practice and it wasn't
because I was in any way qualified by in
fact I was very unqualified for it I
went up managing a team of 50 engineers
frankly because I was you know one of
only five people that knew a lot about
this technology and of the five they're
really two of us who we kind of went all
in this is something we just talked
about to all of our colleagues we're
very excited about really showed a lot
of passion around and we were just a few
months ahead in terms of our expertise
and in terms of our experimentation oh
then everybody else so on your kind of
path from where you sit today whether
you're going into an internship this
summer or whether you've got a job lined
up for the fall you're kind of thinking
about yeah anywhere in between I'd
really encourage you to spend a little
bit of time thinking about nada not a
linear path into a leadership role but
think about an area of expertise that
you can develop where you can be your
organization's most valued expert or
ideally the industry's because their
opportunities there for exponential
leadership growth and those are special
yeah so you're on this path right from
the seats here in today is some big
leadership opportunity there's a there's
a really easy way to screw it up the
thing that I look for in certainly in
great interns that have come to work for
our company great new college hires
great grad college hires great
experience hires great numbers of
management team great board members very
simple it's do people do what they say
they're going to do and it's not this
isn't a big metaphysical thing this is
like hey I'll get you that this
afternoon does it happen that afternoon
or does it not you know I owe this
tomorrow sure I can expect it tomorrow
or not i'm still getting action was
still very embarrassed i told you that i
would get you a set of bullet points to
talk about them on monday it didn't show
up till tuesday morning i'm still
actually a little mortified about that
the reason doesn't matter it's is do you
do what you say you're going to do oh
yeah I had the unfortunate situation by
a couple years ago I had to fire the
highest paid person a big switch
certainly one of the smartest and
absolutely one of the most qualified um
because frankly just they just wouldn't
do what he said he was going to do
there's this really tactical thing that
I'd urge you to practice in the
weather's in an internship or in the
next job and it sounds really simple at
the end of a meeting you just say hey
reiterate here are the things that I
said I was going to do to make sure
everybody's clear and if it's not it's
kind of socially awkward and sometimes
it is you know write an email sometime
that afternoon of that evening this is
hey everybody here's my understanding of
what i said i was going to do i
guarantee it impresses people and it
builds trust and the really vicious
thing about this is if you don't do it
it roads the kind of trust that nobody
will ever tell you you'll never get
feedback about this until it's way too
late it'll never show up on a
performance review it will never show up
from a friendly colleague it just
doesn't show up until it way way way
past the point when it matters the
beyond just doing it for yourself I've
worked on some high performance
organizations and frankly I've worked in
some pretty low performance
organizations and the high performance
organizations over and over there's
staff with a lot of people who just do
this what they say they're going to do
and the team level shows up to high
performance organization and the
marketing team contents do it they say
they're going to do sales team doesn't
engineering team does it and in the
lower performing ones in my experience
you wind up with well maybe marketing
will deliver this but maybe they won't
cells have a plan B maybe engineering
will do this but maybe they won't so
let's have a plan B or Plan C maybe say
also deliver this but maybe they won't
so it's I've planned a b c and d and by
the time you get to the end of it this
stuff just doesn't make sense anymore
you're managing a meeting where
everybody's got three four five
contingency plans and you waste so much
time energy just trying to get something
simple done so on your path from where
you sit today to a big leadership
position just keep this in mind yeah so
whether it's a formal or an informal
leadership spot and whether it's some
you know big presentation or whether
it's a tricky one on one conversation
the brutal facts is that in your first
few tries you probably mess it up now
the hope is that if you think about the
stockdale paradox you'll either not mess
it up very often or you'll recover
quickly enough that you get to keep this
leadership position you've worked so
hard to get good to great it's an
interesting book it's a good read but
specifically the section of it that I
think is really really important Admiral
Stockdale has his own very interesting
backstory but for this purpose the stock
tail paradox is this essence of when
you're communicating in a leadership
situation balance the brutal facts with
the preservation of hope
I just hope that everybody remembers
this balance the brutal facts with the
preservation of hope via in we had a
company meeting I think this is back in
like early 2012 we had a brutal run up
you know two months of everybody in the
office yeah every weekend a ton of 20
hour days to get into our first you know
this was a really really big customer
trial we were going into and the
customer kicked us out he and this
wasn't like hey we'd had many trials and
this was the first one we got kicked out
of this was our first trial and we got
kicked out and so the company's there
for the all hands meeting on Friday and
I and I was actually the one kind of you
know to talk everybody through it I'd
read this great article about Coach K at
Duke he's got this neat style saying hey
look it's not about winning or losing
it's about whether or not you gave it a
hundred percent I had this in my head
it's really inspired um and if it works
for him it turned on work for me the I
think I kind of got the brutal facts
part but over the course the hour I kind
of missed the preservation I hope bit
yeah it was really bad um that afternoon
for people almost quit the company and I
have five people over the weekend five
people I really like and trust tell me
about that was the worst leadership talk
I have ever seen so the brutal facts are
the first couple times bragging screw
this up with the hope is if you think
about the stockdale paradox when you're
in one of these situations you'll do a
better job than I did
yeah so say things are growing for you
and they're going really well I don't
know how many people I for my chats with
child Chad nakash I'm guessing it's a
fair number people in this room where
you want to go into some kind of tech
whether it's a new tech product new tech
category or something if you if your
choice is a is an enterprise technology
and you're kind of looking at a new
product category type of thing this
should be on your desk please read it
and please read it and give it away to
other people because I found as if just
as a common vocabulary this has matched
my last five years exactly so I actually
personally signed our first two million
dollar customers and I was big part
sourcing our first multi-million dollar
partnership and one of the you know we
can talk about the chasm bit but I think
one of Moore's really interesting
perspectives is that you have this group
of people called the visionaries and now
the visionaries are a little quirky to
work with in the budget they're very
demanding but when you find visionaries
the people who love new technology and
they're willing to take new technology
for new technology's sake and sitting
somewhere near them as an early adopter
and you think of the early adopter as an
upwardly generally an upwardly mobile
professional very very practical
incredibly busy and they have budget and
they're looking for some kind of change
agent in the organization and they're
interested in using technology to do it
I think the point that more makes is
that you can't skip a step here you
kinda have to win the first group to get
to the second group and they're the
gatekeepers for you for the mass market
you can't really go to the early
adopters because they're using a
visionary some friend of theirs somebody
in their organization to serve almost as
a pre-filter and so once you win the
hearts and minds of the visionaries then
you kind of get the
right to get on the calendar for the
early adopter this match is so closely
to what we have been through I can say
on an individual level at a company and
a team level it is so close and it
really changes the way that you think
about who are you know you always go for
the person the organization that is the
budget well the answer is you know when
you have a new product category no not
really if you're thinking about kind of
you know ever in your life doing a
disruptive new product category play
something really world has never seen
before there's no budget line item for
it really read this and i highly
encourage you to spend some time
actually giving this book to the people
around you it matches my experience
exactly
this was what I almost actually didn't
put this slide in has anybody in this
room X you read this book yeah it's a
yeah it's a brutally candid and its
critics say too candid you know I take
perspective on human nature it's pretty
ugly yeah I actually first read it in
grad school and it didn't really
resonate with me at all so if you read
it soon might not make a whole lot of
sense but I read it again at different
points in my career right again last
year and I want to motivate this by
telling you a story we had this big
strategy debate it early in the company
about the fate of an early generation of
the product content of the debate
doesn't matter much but I was spending I
was spending my days flying all over the
country just working with our customers
and partners to desperately try to make
sure that our trials were going well I
was doing my day job and I thought that
I was doing incredibly well at it I was
via on the strategy debate I felt very
very passionately about one side of the
debate the guy on the other side was
spending his time meeting with different
members of management team often
promising them things that in my mind
had nothing to do with a strategy debate
at hand was calling in two board members
and spending time with members of our
board talking about his side of the his
side of this debate I had conversation
i'll never forget with one of our board
members out of trust very very deeply
i'm like halfway through laying out what
i think are very well prepared arguments
for this thing and he stops me a sec
I'll you're probably right and it
doesn't matter
they said you're very worried about
getting the right strategy and the
person sitting on the other side is very
concerned about winning the debate and
let me be brutally honest with you I
want to be on the winning side I don't
care that you're right I'm voting the
other way like it or not and I i always
have a hard time with this this is part
of the fabric of getting things done in
an organization of any size highly
recommend you read this book and if if
you really don't like it read it twice
this was a much happier one that's like
the heavy bit and this isn't a book
actually but I didn't want to change the
title slide this is just a YouTube video
it's like 20 minutes but simon Sinek is
interesting philosopher and writer and
uh he's got this perspective he says if
you want to inspire people to action
instead of talking about what you do
then how you do it then why you do it
lead with why you do it uses Apple is a
great example a think different now we
design beautiful products that people
like to use when I happen to be
computers and phones and business uses
the Wright brothers as a really
interesting example you know the Wright
brothers had their team had this mission
of building the best airplane that they
possibly could samuel pierpont langley
steam kind of the the competitor scene
had them out funded ten to one that is
incredible you know luminary thinkers on
the team but their mission in the void
of any articulation of it was we want to
be famous and we want the fortune that's
going to come with building the first
airplane and when the wright brothers
through a you know quirk of luck and
fate and a lot of blood sweat and tears
got the first airplane up and running
the Langley team completely
disintegrated the right where the steam
extras kept on going they had plenty
more inventions after that via I spent
I have spent about a little over a year
as the vp of marketing for big switch
and you know I when I kind of first
started it our self-described mission
was something along the lines of we
build Software Defined Networking style
operating systems for bare metal switch
hardware's to power next generation
package brokers and leave spine l2 l3
class which when switching fabrics and
like that means a lot to people in our
industry but it took us about a hundred
drafts to come up with something a
little bit different that something was
we believe that the network advances
that have been made by Google Amazon
Facebook and Microsoft should be within
reach of a much broader audience it's it
was funny to see us kind of converged on
this the external messaging is you know
that kind of is what it is I part work
very very well but interesting thing to
me was the internal alignment I got to
tell you like people just seem more
excited about coming to work so that it
takes a ton of drafts to find one of
these leadership statements that's not
so high level and vague that it's
meaningless it's like a food bank like I
know 10 blocks from my house you know it
says like our mission is to feed the
world's hungry food back near duboce
park in san francisco like it's a little
bit of a mismatch and then it's really
hard to come up with something that's
not so detailed that it doesn't really
resonate so getting the getting the
right level in there is something that
takes drafts and if you find yourself in
a leadership spot and you're trying to
articulate your own why and you're
trying to articulate your organization's
why I urge you to have patience take the
time that that's going to require to do
100 drafts and the end result of all
this work is probably very very short so
I
I love this TED talk the second and last
one Seth Godin is another interesting a
writer philosopher via the concept of
this book is that many of us spend just
enough time in our respective fields to
get to a certain level of competence but
we crowd our plates very very full we
don't quit other things and as a result
we don't have the time or the energy or
the emotional bandwidth that it takes to
become one of the best in our field and
the demand for the best in the field is
you know ten exo's for those of us in
the middle of the field I really love
that you know go to use as examples from
professional athletes a lot of world
class musicians it's kind of neat to
seemly out the whole argument but you
know it resonated to me resonated for me
when I spent most of my career at cisco
in between Cisco and big switch I left
for a TV over the internet startup this
was before hulu via and after three
years like just I mean I was just
absolutely working my tail off and you
know trying to soak up as much as I
possibly could about a/b testing
consumer internet behavior and prot I
was out of product management design so
I gotta spend a ton of time working on
design sense at the end of that I was
like pretty good at two things but I
wouldn't really great it either and so I
quit I went back to networking and now I
can look back on it and it hasn't even
been that long but you can see that the
benefits of just sticking with it start
to accrue exponentially you'd be amazed
like this is a now we're going like a 50
billion dollar industry
but the number of people who drive it is
very very small on both the vendor side
and the customer side at this point for
me it's like the same names just keep on
coming up over and over again and more
and more often it's oh yeah you know I
almost recruited him a couple years ago
I almost went to work for her back in
you know back in the day off yeah of
course we've done business together this
was different business cards but the
idea that unfortunately I have to quit a
lot of things and you have to quit a lot
of them early in order to find one thing
that you want to stick with and be one
of the tops in your field this to me is
something that I think about more and
more because you really want to think
about what you need to give up in order
to do that and the hard decisions for me
or not hey what do you want to be great
at the really hard decisions or what do
you wanna give up along the way that's
actually what kind of took the took the
real think in time yeah you know we've
kind of talked this whole time about
career stuff sort of i assume what
everybody for the most part here is for
you can have a good month and you can
have a bad year and you can have a bad
two years and you can have about five
years doesn't always work out even with
these books that i recommend i
recommended them to a lot of people and
sometimes they work for some people
sometimes they don't sometimes they work
for me at some times in my life and
sometimes they haven't my biggest
recommendation is find a hobby that you
love i love cooking i think at this
point I'm pretty good at it and unlike
any of the other books that I've brought
up here this one is guaranteed to work
there 1 i'll leave it there and up we
can go to question
your biggest challenge at founding swish
never have your comments the would you
think was the most significant sure you
know it was awkward enough like the
first couple years we didn't have I
don't think the challenges were so
significant we did incredibly well out
of the gate after the after the
acquisition of our of our competitor and
partner it was the what do we do next
and it wasn't figuring it out everybody
had an idea actually very strongly held
opinion it's a you get a group of people
who really truly believe and understand
that's not their jobs that are online
the jobs don't matter right it's that
the reputations are on the line and that
matters a lot and so getting this group
of people each of whom have a strongly
held belief about what the plan needs to
be and an increasingly escalating amount
of commitment on what this means for my
reputation that's really really really
hard that was it that was the toughest
challenge overcame a big switch balance
becoming an expert at something with
getting the rent that you need to sort
of know what you want the expert in yeah
I took I'm going to be a terrible person
to answer this question because I spend
a lot of my time kind of dabbling in
other areas for me at least and it's
very personal the hard thing has not
been what I want to be an expert in
that's kind of evolved very organically
I mean you haven't 10 years ago it's
going to be an expert in starting
networking companies it would not have
believed that thought the day-to-day
decision is we decide to quit along the
way and that at least for me that
actually winds up being much more top of
mind and sort of force to be up less
than less moon as I'm sure you know is
you have less and less and less time you
know
what are the little things you decide to
give us that for me has been the hard
copies we agree that a majority of the
quintessential leadership qualities are
all about making the uncommon common
sense comments making the uncommon sense
common yeah all right by that you know
via a ton of it's just getting people on
the same page and I think it's exactly
what you think that's a corollary of
exactly what you just said and some of
that shared vocabulary some of that's
understanding that you're on very
different page from somebody else from a
risk profile it takes kind of a long
time and a lot of conversations to
figure out so yeah yeah I would agree
with that statement seriously the book
that you have recommended crossing the
chasm that the Bible is indicative of
the content thank you the there are two
useful parts of that book the one that I
wind up using a lot is it actually gives
names and labels to these different
segments you know the visionary the
early adopter the early majority late
majority laggards that's the part of the
book that for me becomes important
because it's a vocabulary hey why are
you spending a ton of time and money and
energy talking to this particular person
oh because they're a visionary okay
everybody knows what that means they
have no budget oh yes but their
visionary okay I get it hey this person
is an early adopter well we really want
to change exactly how we're addressing
them okay wait this person's early
majority you know they care about his
benchmarking so it gives a really
release full volley to discuss the
people outside the company that you're
talking to and also for me as a
retrospective to recognize where you sit
in that in that spectrum and to
recognize their people who share very
different value systems to let into the
radio the book makes a huge point the
name really comes from there's a big
chasm between the early adopters and the
and the early majority and that's a very
useful concept too and it has all kinds
of ideas on how to cross that chasm it's
extraordinarily useful I found that to
me more of a practical
it's a very practical concept the
vocabulary is the reason that I give the
book to other people can you expand on
why being say marginally better than the
next by people fix you some time for the
man so I don't think it's marginally
better i think it's and i'm not this
month saying i am but i think it's being
recognized as one of the best in the
field i mean i think of when we've gone
out to hire members the management team
when we've gone out to hire really
critical members of the engineering
staff we're going to hire really
critical members of our sales staff of
our marketing staff or business
development staff we have this exercise
that i really like doing okay let's get
a group of people in the room let's list
across all of our experience who we
believe the top 10 individuals are in
the industry and let's throw incredible
amount of love to them to see if they'll
come over to this to work for us that's
a great exercise we've had some
phenomenal people come to work a big
switch doing exactly that I advise other
startups you know it and I kind of
usually start with that you also wind up
seeing that that group of people you
know you they have a ton of job options
it's they're incredibly hard to recruit
because the world is sort of their
oyster because there's so many
conference rooms filled with white
boards where somebody's listing ten
names so I I don't think it's about
being marginally better I'm not saying
I'm one of them but for different
functions i I've been a big part of
putting those ten names up on a
whiteboard and part of that process of
trying to recruit those people and I see
the other options they have in their
amazing and I see how much we pay and
it's amazing yeah so it's a I do think
it's something that's worth thinking
about as part of your it's not like part
of a career plan but it's kind of part
of the picking what to quit and went to
quit it
the time you started and now how are
they industry changed do this one
they're completely yeah yeah yeah and I
I don't wanna spend too much time on the
networking industry because my guess is
that's of interest to like seven or
eight of us via but this industry went
friday let me give you a good example I
think one of the one of the really good
journalists in our space at this great
article sank a data center networking
has seen more innovation in the last two
years than the last 20 and I like to
think that this whole sdn movement has
been a big big part of that this is an
industry that the fundamental basis a
competition with speeds and feeds for 20
years an end result is that the products
are impossible used completely
impossible and arcane to use and when
you see something like sdn come in and
fundamentally change the basis of
competition you see everybody scramble
to try to figure out is change are we
gonna win I'm going to lose and the
industry is in a completely different
place I'm actually very proud of the
industry in general there's much more
focus on on the human sounds funny to
say but a set of you know instead of the
throughput
three questions what is inside roll your
own organization he talked a little bit
about the previous organization
decisions always when she optima might
have been a power play what are you
doing inside your own form exactly
optimal decisions the i think there are
two things recognizing what's a hard
decision that's we're spending a lot of
time on and recognizing what's kind of
stew something you got it you have to do
and move on that's that's the to me
that's the number one hardest thing the
other thing that we do and I egg I give
a ton of credit to out to the other
members of the management team for this
that I work with very closely day-to-day
there's a lot of talk about okay how
should a decision like this be made who
is going to make decisions like this you
know how are we going to make this
particular decision and is it going to
be a little different from how in
general we're going to make this type of
decision so there's this sort of got a
meta conversation about the decision to
be had and the real scripts to mirror
when you skip that step now the trick is
a at the very beginning and some you can
you recognize hey this is a hard one
it's worth having the meta conversation
versus this meta conversation is going
to take us one two three meetings maybe
and we need a decision by the end of the
day will you learn from an OEM and a
customer to a gret yeah she talked a
little bit reductive the big transition
was that a desperation or intent yeah or
just pure crazy a little bit of both I
think the first we started the company
since I worked in cisco I was
desperately scared the cisco Salesforce
like petrified I've ever having to go up
against them as a start-up and as a
company evolved and partially I think is
frankly from somewhere betas the product
really really really well we just got
emboldened to say hey you know have a
16,000 person sales force can we really
go up against that well when you have
the opportunity to be product lead and
your primary sales motion is it can I
put you on
phone with somebody who's using it you
know suddenly kind of feels like it's
not a crazy fight to pick experiences
the Union fell during the startup and
maybe to get funding yeah on the
physical sense from the career sense so
there were few they had very early on I
think one of the things that we did that
created it you usually hear about these
near-death experiences in the first year
or two when we started the company the
third week of the company we had a three
hundred seventy five thousand dollar
government contract so we were like
profitable at three weeks and that was
this incredible forcing function because
you could say hey you know both for
recruiting and hey to hold the team
together and instead of the near-death
experience yeah this kind of nice like
hey we sign this 375,000 other contract
and now we actually really have to
deliver it and it's going to take like a
year so I think that for us that for me
it's a best practice of starting a
start-up can you start with a contract
and it creates a cohesive miss around
the team and it buffers you from these
incredible rollercoaster of the what
could otherwise be a rough first 12
months arda near-death experiences
happen much more later you know when we
had to suddenly instead of being a
component in the technology stack I'm
going to be the entire technology stack
and they were less than your death
experiences because frankly we had
raised a ton of money so while a number
the my friends who have started
companies and some of the startups where
I play an advisory role that near-death
experience is something that kind of
happens a lot we got lucky I just didn't
happen to us and anywhere near a severe
reform as it happened to others
having worked at disco and now competing
against them what's it like in heart the
and you know I think you respect the
company more when you're outside of it
competing against it than when you're
inside of it I found this true cross
we've heard a bunch of people not only
from Cisco but from a whole series of
different networking incumbents from
VMware from a whole bunch and when
you're inside the bowels of a big
company I think very often people you
lose sight of all the things that
company does well are very few people
out there who work for a big company and
say the company they work for is
well-managed does never see that and
then they get outside of it they're
competing against now wow I place
actually pretty well well run with Cisco
specifically I had the luxury of I spent
a fair amount of my time at Cisco
wanting to do a start-up and pattern
matching against the startups that I
felt we're doing a really good job of
competing against Disko so I kind of
left the company with a little bit of a
scene in this playbook work twice you've
seen this play work work three times
I've seen this playbook never work it's
very industry-specific if you want to
compete within a comment I would
actually recommend trying to go work
there even if it's only for a year you
develop an awful lot of opinions about
what works and what doesn't work
so much an effective leadership has to
do with being consciously confident
about your superpowers and also being
aware of here unconscious in confidence
how do you as a start-up founder who
acts as your sounding board other than
your wife who actually your sounding
board to make sure that the assumptions
and remaining RFP in the language where
you want to be doing it's a really good
and very practical question because the
oh sure the so let me correct me if I
paraphrase it I paraphrase a little off
but who's your sounding board when it
comes to unconscious and competence you
know who do you go to for advice who do
your own ideas past the first version
this presentation was a lot walk here
and two thanks to my wife you got to see
a much cleaned up version you know my
wife always winds up being my first
sounding board and that's just the type
of marriage that we have the you know
certainly other members the management
team and you know on different topics I
think it's really really important just
he sort of said out hey beyond
everybody's functional experience and I
shouldn't say management team actually
the very much the broader team like
beyond the kind of functional day-to-day
are you cultivating relationships with
the people that you work with to have
the one-on-one really private
conversation to say look this idea is
unformed it's maybe going to be a little
far off it maybe sounds yeah it sounds
good to me in my head but let's try it
out in the real world there's a danger I
don't see it in my current but I've been
in organizations where I've been in this
position I've seen other people in this
position in the past if you always wind
up if you're in a leadership spot and
you wind up always going to the same one
or two people it creates its own weird
dynamic the so the healthier dynamic
that I've seen is kind of a sort of
lonely spot at times
that hey for conversations like this you
know for topics like this here's the
go-to person for topics like this here's
my sounding word person topics like this
here's my third the management team is
incredibly useful independent board
members or people who you should roll
out very very deeply and spend a lot of
time thinking about be one on your
independent board our first independent
board member was one of my teachers here
in the msn 82-73 class taxi how we first
met the independent board members a key
different members of the team are
incredibly key families incredibly key I
have it I've had at times an executive
coach you'd be amazed at how many people
do have that that's been extraordinarily
useful and that's usually my set the
failure mode I think that I would point
out is when it's like you're in a
leadership role or somebody in the
company's in the leadership role and I
always have one or two go two people
those one or two go two people wind up
having so much inside information they
get out sighs power and it can be really
tricky to manage when they yeah there
are a lot of different ways with that
can go go wrong and it makes everybody
else feel very left out
turtle corporation keep growing growing
and becoming a like an engine fire it is
a value versus this cultural
bureaucratic culture no official
imbecility bureaucratic elephantiasis
than weapon via my company were not
there yet but I'd love to tell you the
let me give you a I think that's a good
question it deserves a good example um I
was working in a sort of strategy group
at Cisco when John Chambers put out you
know the sort of this vision is target
he's really good at this stuff and when
you actually kind of did the back the
envelope on the targets to achieve the
target the company would have to add a
fortune 500 size company every year for
the next five years that's like guy and
they did it it was one of these wild
things of seeing a leader at a company
of that size and scale who could still
have a vision that was so big that it
was a real challenge you know ever in
the company I think more people would
have thought it was crazy if he didn't
have such a long track record of doing
exactly this to me it's something that's
incredibly inspiring I remember sitting
in a room with a bunch of people working
on market sizing and spreadsheets and
how can we take existing product lines
and acquisitions in this whole business
and it was incredibly inspiring to see
it you know at amazon like sometimes
i've heard them called the 2x in the 10x
vision and see even if that scale having
a 10x vision when it's so easy to have a
2x vision the bigger companies that i
think at least in industries that I've
competed in and I haven't worked at
others but
they seem to spend much more time on a
2x vision and even a nuts scale they
lose the sense of what a 10x vision
could really be
you